right now we're continuing to look at
integration by substitution here's an
example what do you think before we get
to this example of what would you look
at integration by substitution so far
don't need to write this down but if you
have a think about something like this
here's an example which looks remarkably
similar or something we looked at before
and we saw that basically if you do a
bit of twisting and turning you can use
integration by substitution and you can
see this should turn into a sine inverse
basically you're going to need to muck
around with the coefficient because of
the 409 there but it's not complicated
and when we are doing this by
integration by substitution I love you
point out to me that's a bit longer like
there's just so extra work rather than
twisting this into a common form saying
Let X equal etcetera etcetera Sara ended
up with like depending on the way you
write it on two to three times water
lines at least and doesn't mean two to
three twelve times more work some of the
lines were very easy to establish like
when you make a substitution that you
find out the preview those are really
really simple but all the same the
question was why
when I approach this by integration by
substitution when we already have
techniques that will take care of this
quite adequately and the answer is there
are integrals like this one where the
techniques we have like this just trying
to twist it around and not adequate
so despite has some of these kinds of
integrals law this represents a much
bigger problem now before I can't one
more thing I want to say before we dive
into this particular board this is a
hard problem this is about as hard as it
gets really in some ways for integration
in extension one
it's definitely extension one not a
two-unit question because there's no
boundaries there are no boundaries now
you wouldn't think that having
boundaries make that much of a
difference but if you think about a
question like this
at this time what was really hard for it
into a really easy question this is very
very simple assault because as you know
if you think about what this shape is
this is just a semicircle it's just a
semicircle and integration is all about
what's the area underneath the curve now
all in one is I can destroy anyone's IQ
if all that one is the area of a
semicircle then I don't need calculus to
work that out I can just say well it's
going to be raised three and I said well
PI R squared in this case would be pi
times nine nine pi I mean one half of
the thing so it would be 9 PI over 2 and
that's the answer to this this is just a
number right a definite integral just
corresponds to an area however if you
take away please just this little small
piece of information that's missing now
makes this dramatically hot so how are
we going to go about it well just like
we've seen before
the key is to choose an appropriate
substitution now it doesn't look at
mediately obvious what substitution
should be managing okay now I will point
out it's extension one students you will
very very commonly be given the
substitution okay they'll say just try
this let X equal this and then see what
my fault okay but before we actually
show you I want you to remember
if it's a semi-circle right one of the
things that we learn about circles
before is that you can represent them
with with X's and Y's but you can also
think about them parametrically you can
think about a point on a circle in terms
of an angle like this and the radius
you've got there okay so being that we
understand things parametrically or at
least we can and sometimes that is usual
it's not that crazy an idea to say well
can I use parametric's to help me here
okay now remembering that on the unit
circle every every set of coordinates on
the unit circle is cos theta sine theta
because there is an idea this is not
unit circle this circle is artlessness
bigger than this has a radius of 3
so therefore the parametric coordinates
for this are not because the assigned
leaner they're going to be 3 cos theta 3
sine theta
look at this I can use that I can use
that to my advantage
right instead of saying let's just speak
about this in terms of X's and Y's I'm
going to introduce well let's let's
introduce a fear into this okay I'm in
the treat function so in this case
particularly for notifier is I'm going
to say let's let X equal 3 sine theta ok
very interesting exercise for you to see
what happens if let next if you let X
equal 3 cos theta but as I think you'll
see as we go through this proof it
doesn't make that much of a difference
okay I'm gonna try this out now there's
the first piece if I use that and start
changing the function there but I also
need to see what happens to that
variable integration
I've got a DX there you know so what am
I going to use to translate back and
forth between those I'm gonna
differentiate
now even though we were used to
differentiating with respect to X that's
because usually XP independent variable
it's the thing over here at the right
hand side you've got something which is
a function of X but I've done a
substitution it's not a function of X
anymore
it's a function of theta so that's why
I'm differentiating with respect to
theta okay now sign Sibley's nodes into
cosine and this this is good but how I
use this to get rid of this DX
essentially what I want is for D theta
of dance to appear in my equation over
here because then I can multiply through
by that and the over DX will cancel with
dnt R and I'll be left with everything
in terms of D Thea's that's what I want
it looks to me like the easiest way to
get it get the dental and denominator is
to divide both sides
by TX of Athena if I divide both sides
by now
the left hand side obviously it just
becomes one and we're good right hand
side being divided by DX mu theta that
means I'm taking the reciprocal so
that's D theta D X 1 D theta so this is
good and as we pointed out before the
reason why this is useful is because now
I have about 10 times 1 I have one
everywhere like I can substitute 1 into
whatever I like and that's exactly what
I'm going to do so now that I've got
these pieces that's all I really need to
start translating this thing I just said
that 9 minus x squared it's gonna be 9
minus this square so I'm going to go
ahead and make that substitution and now
you can start to see why this isn't just
like that of know where this is going to
become something useful for me right
I've now got this guy but I'm going to
cancel him with that so I will put all
the pieces in place so I can do that
I've got my D theta of DX and then I've
got my DX that was already there
see you can see these two guys go to
cancel with each other so they disappear
as I do that happen to the next moment
of it is simplifying here as well
think carefully I've got an integral I
can take out a factor of the square root
of 9 which of course is just a 3 wait
that's an square root and then under
here I have 1 minus sine square theta 1
by sine theta I of course know is cos
squared field which is true for all
values of theta now what's left over
here I've got three cars neither my D
axis or cancel so I'm just left with
this via this is really nice where can I
go forward from here I can take out the
3 squid they don't use you not me
but then I'm going to pause ok because
it's a simple thing to say of the square
root of a square is just whatever that
thing was right the square root of the
square 3 should be 3 right except we
know we've looked at this before that
they know the square root of a square
number the tricky thing about it is if
you put a negative number into here a we
say a negative number when you go
through this process of squaring taking
the square root you don't end up with a
if everything you're going to end up
with
the absolute value of n okay this is
something that we are we looked at
briefly when we were doing inverse
functions that because you don't get any
best function when you just do the
taking the inverse of the square you get
an inverse relation we have to strictly
defined the square root as a positive
only so this is what's going to happen
over here right it's a very very common
error to just say are the square root
cause where this cause it's not if the
absolute value
odd cause
okay this is a little bit awkward does
it matter
the answer is yes it does the
illustration you want if you think about
what this graph looks like what is this
did I change this question down right
will it did this and they fill up same
circle look basically what I read is now
okay well it's the product of two
functions okay so I can consider the two
different pieces and see what happens
and I multiply them together cosine or
not that looks like
that looks like do we break let's just
do it from know what to do I have to
keep going but I'm gonna get everything
I need you that's what regular cosine
looks like what were the absolute value
of cosine look like well everywhere that
cosine is positive the absolute value of
cosine is just cosine right so this blue
dotted graph is my absolute value plus
theta but then if he has away from the
luma through all the other absolute
value graphs will be drawn in the past
what happens is you get the reflection
across the axis right so you're gonna
get this kind of shape here now this is
she hit okay but we could deal with this
right now I'm trying to work out what
does the graph look like and is this x
is now as extension one student it's a
little bit outside the scope of what
we're doing you know compounding for you
together multiply them but we can still
work this out and extension to students
should be able to do this in a leafless
let's watch this okay what I'm gonna do
is thinking about some important values
here and then see what happens when I
multiply them okay I'm picky about blue
turns green
this is by blue graph my green graph so
I'm gonna multiply them together and
that would give me the whole function
there are lots of easy values to start
with you
blue x green when theater is equal to
this is inferior access when T is equal
to 0 is 1 times 1 which of course is one
going to bother a t-value T is 0 times 0
is 0 0 times here again 1 times 1 then
it starts to get more interesting when
theta is equal to PI it's halfway along
the graph right I've got this value
which is negative 1 because that's the
range and then I've got this Blue Valley
which is 1 negative 1 times 1 is
negative 1 ok now what are the rest of
this thing look like this is something
extension two students can have a look
at potential wants to don't have to
worry about graphing something is hard
for the sake of it I will just quickly
show you it should
okay if you want it you can use some
calculus to help you with that
the important thing about this is not
the curvature it could cabin area if you
like that the important thing to know is
the part of this graph are negative
that's kind of a problem right I don't
want this to be negative how do I know
there's a couple of different ways to
resolve this I'm going to show you what
a simple one to begin with which appeals
back to this when you have a look at
this original function right they give I
don't have any boundaries but I know it
only exists between negative 3 & 3 and
no matter what boundaries I were to
choose no matter what values a community
now the area underneath this curve is
always going to be positive of course
assuming that growing from small those
two big advantages if you integrate
backwards that's another power so it be
that what you've got here this thing
here
whatever that is you're gonna put in
here you should expect something
positive
it has to be every part of this graph is
above the axis so when you take the
integral you should be getting
everything is a positive everywhere
therefore I translate the problem into
this well in exactly the same way I want
to be expecting that every part of this
should be positive but this part of it
then art okay so therefore I can ignore
on this part that gives me a negative
right
what was it the gambia narrative the
problem was this this blue part up here
I don't think too you might think if
there's some green part because that's
the negative bit but a really issue is
we're going to take just regular color
square regular clothes away which is
just the green rap times the green graph
again a negative times a negative is
going to give you a positive raise the
absolute value that use the problem so
therefore I can say since this is going
to be positive right this has to be
positive for all real values of x that
actually satisfy this integral therefore
this must also be positive right so I
can take the positive case of cosine
right so it's going to give me this
okay so I guess my argument for that
would be since the original integral has
to be positive for all the values for
which it is defined right so since this
guy is positive which is the integral I
started with this one also has to be
positive I can ignore the negative case
right of course we know because they
would equal negative cos theta sorry the
absolute value would equal the negative
sign if I was thinking about what
happens in there but like I'm not I
don't want that negative case I just
want the positive one I think we can all
agree just like every part this is
positive every part of it is will also
be positive
you're pretty real numbers into this you
can square it you get something positive
out okay now that was the hardest part I
think of dealing with this because from
here this is actually a familiar
integral we don't with respect when we
were doing the calculus of trig
functions let alone inverse trig
functions but let's go ahead and finish
it off because this we're still on that
what was yet even though we've done the
husband